point d'interrogation.
Parce qualalalgré la vitesse,
certains n'ont pas jamais émis
de contraventions.
Mathieu Prost.
- Vous avez probablement vu
ces panneaux qui annoncent
surveillance de la vitesse sur
certaines artères de Montréal.
Ce sont des radars mobiles qui
peuvent générer automatiquement
des contraventionscacacas
d'excès de vitesse. Tous les
revenus vont dans un fonds
provincial pour la sécurité
routière. Sept tronçons ont été
retenus en 2016 pour une
surveillance aléatoire.
Certains sont très lucratifs.
Sur Notre-Dame et Sherbrooke par
exemple, 4 millions de dollars
de contraventions ont été émis
l'dedededernière. Mais sur une
artère censée être surveillée,
aucune amende n'a jamais
été émise.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS DAZÉ, directeur
École primaire Saint-Ars
- Assurément, la vitesse, c'est
un élément de danger pour les
piétons, pour les usagers
qui sont à vélo, à mobylette,
en transport actif.- - - - Il ds
écoles primaires qui bordent le
tronçon Christophe-Colomb entre
Rosemont et Crémazie. Trois
kilomètres sur lesquels des
dépassements de vitesse so
pourtant souvent observés.
NICOLAS SAUNIER, prof. Poly. Mtl
spé. questions sécurité routière
- Mais zéro, c'est bizarre.
C'est assez bizarre. Alors queee
très achalandée.
- Dans un courriel, le SPVM
explique que les opérations
de radars mobiles ont été
temporairement suspendues en
2021 sur le tronçon Christophe-
Colomb en raison de la
modification de vitesse
de 50 km/h à 40 km/h et que
l'entente que Montréal a signée
avec le ministère des transports
pour ces radars concerne des
tronçons routiers dont l
vitesse est d'au moins 50 km/h.
Pourtant, le document ne
mentionne aucun seuil de vitesse
pour les artères àleleleleler.
- Justement, il faut vérifier
que quand on baisse la limite de
vitesse e e e e e qui se passe
et si on peut effectivement.
Des mesures de ce type-là vont
augmenter l'adhésion des
condpapapapapar rapport
à la limite de vitesse.
- Ce constat, la directrice
d'une autre école sur le tronçon
n'a pas de mal à
LAILA TAMDA, directrice
École primaire Saint-Étienne
- Je suis étonnée de voir ou de
savoir qu'il n'y a pas... il n'y
a aucune amea a a a a a été
donnée puisque là, c'est comme
il n'y a pas de radars ici,
les véhicules, ils roulent à une
vitesse... je ne pense pas que
çalalalalalala vitesse maximale.
- Ni le MTQ et la ville qui ont
signé l'entente, ni le SPVM qui
exploite les radars, ni la
sûreté du Québec qtrtrtrtrtrtre
les infractions, ni le ministère
de la justice qui émet les
contraventions nnnnnnn
mesure d'expliquer ce radar
fantôme.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréa